former British Prime Minister Tony Blair
he's another one he's a big globalist
too he's another one at the world
economic forum and he wants to bring the
digital infrastructure to your country
so that they can monitor whether you've
been vaccinated or not
you need to know who's been vaccinated
and who hasn't been some of the vaccines
that will come on down the line will be
multiple there'll be multiple shots so
you've got to have the reasons to do
with the healthcare more generally but
certainly for a pandemic or for
and for vaccines you've got to have a
proper digital infrastructure and many
countries don't have that in fact most
countries don't have that no you don't
Tony you little Mickey Mouse looking
weirdo no you don't uh you don't have to
have that how insane is it that as we
are literally right now
every day we find out more and more
about how the vaccines didn't work how
there are all sorts of vaccine injuries
and heart problems and everything else
shouldn't that be what they're talking
about like if these people really cared
about the world they really cared about
Humanity wouldn't they be talking about
boy we have Albert borla here from
Pfizer we've got the moderna guy and
we've got all these world leaders who
you know locked people at home and
forced people out of jobs and you know
didn't let Grandma die peacefully with
the family around her we just threw her
through a ditch in the name of science
or something you wouldn't they be going
guys let's have a meeting to see what we
did wrong here see how it is possible
that these giant pharmaceutical
companies screwed up everything and lied
to everybody and that our communication
and they could even do it in a way that
wasn't all blaming on them they could
say boy we never faced anything like
covet before and we all got a little
ahead of ourselves or whatever but
instead they're trying to figure out
more ways to control us after the next
magical pandemic comes and they did
learn a lesson they really did learn a
lesson during the last pandemic that
people will behave and not only will
people behave as they wish people will
rat out their neighbors people will
punch strangers remember all the videos
during the height of cover these were my
favorite videos when you see someone at
a store someone's not wearing a mask and
then the mask person is chasing the not
masked person to tell tattletail on them
like they're so supposed to be so afraid
of covid wouldn't you be running the
other way generally
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]